члени так давно олеся аня то юля на віті
подумати іншим кути що весь мій друг
збрую
ти перони проходить вежі вулицях у пари
dme склі його
тут просто шва вся навальний tabbert
українську резервну армію стоїть
євграфовича вуста не шляхів у нашій
українці незабаром вже статей актуальні та
люблячі по ви на ринок у метро мати
зброї в руках знака як вона стріляючи весь
кого підготовка за гали потрібно
напрокат я говорила з мамою щось у них
було у школі ризиково підготовка а в нас
нічого такого не буллу я поважаю щось
дрібне дно нинішнього покоління і волали
через ситуацію в Україні найзнатіша
шкіряної ситуації в Україні це повинен знати
кожен
я хочу від тебе запечатую лікувальну
зростання на ботана with you
організатор тренінги геннадій грузинку в
туристів узбережжя сайт aber wenn оренду і
розум за своїм другом вінда монстра і
нам одну скі над домівкою ці учасники
наш чай кореневих і дні на вежі у
приїжджають піф сотні людей фінансує
початковий tabbert за рахунок жертв то
плати за тренінг
дала конів сирим бо і все ж таки року і
котячі росту кит поранені вдасться
пропустить і мільйон людей на адже
китайські армії тут нічого буду роботи я
вже покараю про путінську за день
бойових дій домішок не тіш входу цю
програму ризикового тренінг у дівчат
а в ж пани ділок геть із нових звучно з
едіта мутно університеті лови дівича
харкові та в чати муть і на заміні новий
юриспруденцію сни ось уже жваво будемо
ж у миру та помисли
і всі учасники тренінгу поспішають про
грі туго тайпа пораненого товариша для
дикого вся ситуація вже знайома віджати і
люди побував і друкують на нього та
стріляні на майдані у криві ноги геть і
були безпорадними, а тепер навчилася
оборонятися тут брови в руках я б
дуже хотів чекаю вже хотіла колишнього моє
знання Миколай нас треба було синім і не
нікому сен шуму
сама марія, а ось так я до сьогодні ведіть
россия украина хочу миру алли пу ви на
ранок тис. до провини готується до війни
он і не радикали і немає члена та правого
сектора студенти навчають чи юристи
звучання храму діани лежати тут і їсти
і стріляти і оружня для ви шкалу
організатори мало легально взяв на
прокат у приватному у стрілецькому у клубі
нападали і в день батька трьох дітей нині
он з дружини очі куити 4 дітей ну-ка
лиж не весь ковий поридаю таборі свої
знання їм шин сюди готові саме готові
не бояться води завжди готові до того ж
цифри важливого віруючі люди віку смерті
на бояться який смертю не боятися на
прокиньте нашим дозволяє постріляти і
по довідковому шкірний атрибут і частина
бойових на боїв а б ви пробували свої
навички у рази на йешуа сценарію шляхом у
таборі пройшли підготовку в ж над три
сотні людей
список охочих будинок залізний учасники пар
ікони не щоб вчаться захищатися
європейські цінності он esp одягаєте
htc так вже зрозуміти і в брюсселі і в
берліне у варшаві це ж відразу милий кожен
канаді грузинку
вінці туриста польського друга
європейська нація українці Європа є
канатика з метає що таке ревнощі 6
свобода і готує ці цінності страж
дати і по ми раді поки що в брюсселі диску
тут про форму помідори у брюсселі
дискутуємо а формі помідорів випуск на
кой тренінгу вирішу каналу щоб вони
боролися за українську пукаєш все power to
use додому
готове кубу дикі момент 100 таємниця
захист своєї країни
україні